pabst franziskus schaltet sich mit einer
rührenden geste in den politischen
konflikt im südsudan ein
nach gesprächen mit dem präsidenten zahl
lag ihr sowie dem rebellenführer react
macher im vatikan im roman das
katholische kirchenoberhaupt die
konfliktparteien eindringlich zum
frieden anschließend küsst er beiden die
füße
franziskus kündigt zudem an in kürze in
den süden reisen zu wollen
der südsudan hatte im sommer 2011 seine
unabhängigkeit vom sudan erklärt im
dezember 2013 begann einen bürgerkrieg
in dessen verlauf mehr als 380.000
menschen getötet und vier millionen
südsudanesen in die flucht getrieben
wurden
der konflikt war geprägt von schwersten
menschenrechtsverletzungen und führte zu
einer der größten humanitären krisen
weltweit im september unterzeichneten
die konfliktparteien zwar ein
friedensabkommen es wird aber weiterhin
gekämpft